sur l'aspect les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques sont davantage
intéressés par ce qui par les
traitements que par les systèmes par ce
qui prévient évidemment que oui mais
malheureusement il n'ya pas que les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
il ya les états aussi notre système note
meilleur système de santé au monde mais
on s'est aperçu qu'en dehors du système
curatif y avait pas grand chose
d'accord qu'est ce qu'on a fait comme
réponse au milieu de la crise pour se
dire non mais on a compris on a entendu
on a donné 8 milliards à l'hôpital bien
sûr qu'il fallait qu'ils les salaires à
l'hôpital comme d'ailleurs dans d'autres
institutions sont insuffisantes en
france enfin aussi la seule réponse à la
pandémie c'est une réponse hospitalière
excusez moi c'est pas quand même avoir
tiré les beaucoup de leçons de ce qui se
passe donc si je pense que soit on ne
prend que de négatif de cette crise et
on est en train de le vivre et on ne
fait que la subir
soit on en tire des leçons et on est et
on se donne une capacité de rebond pour
que dans quelques années cette crise non
seulement été effacé sur un plan
économique et social mais nous a permis
véritablement parce que je rejoins ce
qui a été dit au début de l'émission
c'est que le monde d'après doit être
différent du monde d'avant si on ne
prend pas en compte la santé
environnementale de façon un peu plus
sérieuse qu'on ne l'a fait avant il est
évident que d'autres pandémies nous
pendent au nez
les grands scientifiques le disent mais
il n'y a pas besoin d'être un grand
scientifique pour comprendre qui a quand
même eu un dérèglement dans le dans la
biosphère dans le biotope dans notre
relation avec l'environnement qui qui
qui favorise ce genre de crise est là
aussi on voit pas beaucoup et c'est pas
la peine de penser l'europe de penser le
monde déjà comme disait de gaulle c'est
pas la peine de sauter comme un cabri
sur sa chaise en europe nous regardons
déjà
que nous nous trouvons faire
[Musique]